we will now introduce a new kinematic
quantity called angular momentum angular
momentum will be very useful when we
describe the rotation of objects in
particular how it will be related to
torque now what is angular momentum
suppose we have an object of mass M and
it's moving in this direction and it has
a momentum P remember P equals M be
angular momentum is always defined about
some point so suppose we choose a point
s and I wanted to find the angular
momentum about s due to this motion of
the object and the way it's defined is
I'll draw a vector from the point s to
where the object is and our definition
of angular momentum about s is equal
this is three lines for our definition
it's the vector cross product of the
vector RS with the vector P now how do
we define the direction of this vector
well the way we do that for any vector
product is we take the two vectors and
we put them tail the tail so let's start
off by drawing the vector RS in that
direction and now when you take a cross
product we draw an arrow from the first
vector to the second one remember
crossing vector products are the same
thing and now we want to use our right
hand rule to get the direction of the
angular momentum so we curl our fingers
and notice in this case it's pointing
into the plane of the figure and so the
direction of the angular momentum about
s is given into the plane of the figure
in our light board now we'll learn how
to calculate this cross product in
detail but suppose we have our vectors
which are in a slightly different
arrangement as seen in this figure here
well what we see is with the vector P
and the vector RS we still use our right
hand rule to calculate the direction of
L s notice whenever you have a vector
cross product that the vector L s
is perpendicular to both the vectors RS
and is perpendicular to the vector P and
you can see in both of these examples
that the angular momentum is
perpendicular to the plane formed by the
vectors R s and P